House of the Dragon is a Game of Thrones prequel
show that is confirmed by HBO’s president
to air in 2022.
Miguel Sapochnik and Ryan Condal will serve
as showrunners and executive producers. George
R. R. Martin will also serve as executive
producer.
It is based on George RR Martin’s book Fire
And Blood volume 1 and on Martin’s yet unfinished
Fire And Blood volume 2 book.
“Fire & Blood begins their tale with the
legendary Aegon the Conqueror, creator of
the Iron Throne, and goes on to recount the
generations of Targaryens who fought to hold
that iconic seat, all the way up to the civil
war that nearly tore their dynasty apart.”
That's Fire And Blood volume 1.
The yet unreleased Fire And Blood volume 2
will continue from where part 1 ended, with
Rhaenyra Targaryen's son Aegon lll's reign
and will cover Blackyre rebellions, war with
Dorne and go all the way to the Mad King and
Robert's Rebellion that ended Targaryen dynasty.
Robert's Rebellion, also known as the War
of the Usurper, was a rebellion against House
Targaryen, primarily instigated by Eddard
Stark, Jon Arryn, and Robert Baratheon, for
whom it's named.
It lasted "close to a year" and resulted in
the end of the Targaryen dynasty in the Seven
Kingdoms
and the beginning of Robert Baratheon's reign.
The most important battle during this war
and the battle that ultimately determined
the outcome of Robert's Rebellion was the
Battle of the Trident. The battle was fought
between rebel and royal troops at the Trident,
across what would thereafter be known as the
ruby ford.
A legendary duel between Robert and Rhaegar
was a fight which decided the outcome of the
entire battle. The battle was decided when
Robert and Rhaegar met in single combat on
horseback in the stream. Robert eventually
crushed Rhaegar's chest with a blow of his
warhammer.
This battle was the most important event during
the rebellion as it decided the winner of
the war.
However, all the circumstances and the entire
truth will not be known until the final seasons
of House of the Dragon end. What if there
are some secrets we don’t know yet regarding
this battle.
As you may or may not know, Fire & Blood book
on which the upcoming Game of Thrones prequel
is based on is not entirely accurate as it's
not written by George RR Martin's point of
view, but rather George writes it from Maester's
point of view who gathers his information
from other history books and sources alike.
Also, the only characters who saw Rhaegar
fall, saw only the final blow.
What if Robert did not win a fight against
Rhaegar or what if he did, but Rhaegar defeated
him.
What if Prince Rhaegar defeated Robert and
told him to yield since he did not want to
kill him?
Rhaegar told him that Lyanna loves him and
he loves her. Robert yielded, Rhaegar helped
Robert get up and when Rhaegar wasn't ready,
when he put down his sword, at that moment
Robert smashed his warhammer into Prince Rhaegar's
chest. That’s why Robert was never happy.
He knew Lyanna loved Rhaegar and Rhaegar did
not hurt her. Robert knew Rhaegar was a better
fighter. He defeated Rhaegar only because
Rhaegar was too noble and kind to finish him
so Robert used the situation, yielded and
killed him when he was not expecting it. That's
why he drank himself to an early grave, trying
to forget it all. I mean, it's all there.
It's been in front of us for years: during
his battle against Rhaegar, Robert was wounded,
and after that battle, he was never truly
happy. Some say it's because of Lyanna, but
the truth is, Robert never really loved Lyanna
that much. As matter of fact, he slept with
many girls after his marriage was arranged
to Lyanna. In this theory, the truth why Robert
was never happy again after the battle of
the Trident is not only because his betrothed
ran away with Rhaegar out of love and not
against her will, but also because that same
man Lyanna fell in love with, defeated him
in combat and spared his life only for Robert
to kill him out of anger, even though he yielded
and Rhaegar was not expecting it. So basically,
in this theory, Robert knew Lyanna loved Rhaegar
and he loved her. Robert also knew Rhaegar
was a better fighter and he knows he would
have been dead if not for Rhaegar's mercy
and that's why he's been drinking himself
to an early grave ever since. He couldn't
accept it. That’s why Robert dreams of Rhaegar
every night and kills him in his dreams every
night over and over again. It hunts him. That's
one theory and possibility. The other is that
Rhaegar was not even there, did not fight
Robert and did not die there. The story says
Prince Rhaegar met Lord Robert Baratheon in
combat at a ford during the Battle of the
Trident, where the pair had a legendary duel
in the raging rivers of the Trident. Rhaegar
despite wounding Robert, was struck down with
a massive blow from Robert's warhammer, which
scattered rubies encrusted in Rhaegar's armor
under the water.
It's said that "rubies flew like drops of
blood from the chest of a dying prince and
he sank to his knees in the water and with
his last breath murmured a woman's name".
While Rhaegar laid dead in the stream, soldiers
of both armies scrabbled in the water to search
for the rubies. Later the location was named
the ruby ford. First let’s point out the
obvious - it's especially highlighted that
Rhaegar wore his iconic night-black plate
armor with the three headed dragon of House
Targaryen decorated in rubies on its breastplate.
Additionally, the ford in which this battle
took place is named for the rubies that were
knocked from Prince Rhaegar's breastplate.
Now, why is it so important for George RR
Martin as well as for the showrunners to make
it very clear that Rhaegar wore his iconic
armor that had rubies attached to it. Why
so much focus on Rhaegar's rubies? Why is
it such a big plot point and subject brought
up whenever the battle of the Trident or Rhaegar
are brought up? The first theory would be
that Robert did not fight Rhaegar, but rather
someone else who had glamoured himself in
the form of Rhaegar using rubies. As it was
confirmed in the sixth season of Game of Thrones,
rubies can be used to glamor its owners into
a form or person they want to be. Melisandre
uses it to hide her true form of an extremely
old woman. In the books, Mance Rayder glamored
to appear as Rattleshirt via the ruby in his
wrist cuff.
The power in rubies is something called glamor
where you can basically use them with the
power of the lord of light to project a different
image of yourself. If Melisandre and Mance
can use it,
it's most certainly not out of the realm of
possibilities that someone had glamoured himself
in the form of Rhaegar using these same rubies
- and sacrificed his life for beloved Prince.
The other theory that is also supported says
that someone else died instead of Rhaegar
wearing his iconic armor. Remember that in
the books because he'd been covered from head
to toe in armor, Dany did not see his face
in the vision. Perhaps Rhaegar never died
on the Trident. While the first theory says
it was someone who used rubies to glamor himself
in the form of Rhaegar, the second one has
less magic and states it was simply one of
the kingsguard members who fought Robert,
dressed up in Rhaegar's full armor. Throughout
the books we've been given a few major examples
of an ordinary fighter wearing his hero's
armor to sacrifice his life for him and his
cause. In a Clash of Kings, Ser Rodrik Cassel
attempted to put an end to Ramsay and his
atrocities. Rodrik's party comes across Ramsay
during one of his hunting trips, but Ramsey
is able to survive by switching clothes with
his personal servant who is then killed in
his place. Basically Ramsay gave him his clothes
and markings of identity whereupon Rodrik's
men killed the servant believing him to be
Ramsay. Another example can be found in the
legendary last fight between Robar Royce (the
last of Bronze Kings) and Artys Arryn, the
founder of House Arryn. It says it was dusk
when Artys and his Andal army finally appeared.
But even in that fading light, Robar Royce
did not fail to mark their leader. His silvered
armor and winged helm made the Falcon Knight
unmistakable, even from afar. After the first
6 charges against Robar's line failed, Artys's
falcon shaped helmet appeared in the heat
of the battle. Robar charged at him in the
hope that the Andal army would dissolve if
their leader was killed. There we had two
legendary heroes meeting and fighting in a
duel except for a fact one of them was just
an ordinary knight. Robar beheaded the Falcon
Knight after a duel, only to see five hundred
fresh Andal knights charging at him with the
real Falcon Knight, Artys Arryn, at their
head. Cunning even more than brute force,
Artys had clad one of his knights in his own
distinctive armor to distract Robar. Afterward,
Artys became King of the Mountain and the
Vale and founded house Arryn. Those are two
examples of someone else wearing their hero's
iconic armor to sacrifice his life for him
and his cause. There's definitely a reason
why George RR Martin is giving us these examples.
There's also one detail from the popular episode
Blackwater that supports this theory. When
that episode had come out, George RR Martin
was pretty upset that main characters like
Stannis and the Hound were not wearing their
helmets during the battle. At first glance
it might seem strange that George would complain
about such a small detail, but it actually
makes perfect sense. For him to later reveal
that Rhaegar never fought Robert on the Trident,
a big deal would obviously be made about one
member of the kingsguard wearing Rhaegar's
armor and helm. But those are just theories
and that's all we have until Game of Thrones
prequel series, House of the Dragon, comes
out. Every question, doubt or proof we are
looking for will be answered or confirmed
in 2022 on HBO. Thank you so much for watching,
if you enjoyed this video make sure to give
it a big thumbs up and I hope to see you in
the next one.
Peace!